- I think we don't talk enough
about how no and failures
are the foundations for yes and wins.
(upbeat music)
(yells)
You got your perspective.
(audience cheers)
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeat music)
(audience applauds)
If you're like me and you're over 40,
you actually remember
the world pre-internet.
Which for a lot of people
in here doesn't exist,
and so from afar,
he hates when I pontificate about this,
but when you are literally the leader
the rain maker of Hollywood,
during a pre-internet world,
you are not only at the top of Hollywood,
you know you're talking
to somebody that thinks
that Hollywood has been the great engine
that has built the American brand
over the last hundred years.
So if you think about having a decade
when nothing significant
doesn't run through you
or your organization,
there is no current comp in our society
of like dictating culture
because the internet has amortized it out
to a lot of leaders.
And so when you think about
four to five or six or
seven individuals' map
to the level of, it's not a money thing,
it's an impact on culture and
really just a level of power,
we just, there aren't a lot of individuals
who've had a run on dictating
what this country consumed
and thus the world more
than what Michael did
at the top of CAA.
- What did you learn from him,
observing him the last 20 years?
- Being obnoxiously powerful is cool.
I'm kidding, I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
I think what, I think it's a
little bit different, actually.
I have a very nuanced answer.
That is definitely not what I learned,
and not something I think a lot about.
What I did learn, though,
or more importantly,
as I started digging into Michael's career
as my career changed, and you would just,
cause I didn't really grow up
with a eye towards Hollywood,
A, all my buddies, and pals and friends
that looked toward L.A. and Hollywood
of a certain age, this
is like way up there.
Number two, my whole career, right now,
I'm currently building
a company that's goal
is to buy IP and businesses in the future,
and repackage them and merchandise them.
I think a lot of entrepreneurs here,
and not only entrepreneurs, non-profits,
politicians, taste makers, whatever
your goals and ambitions are, a lot of you
are missing, everything's right,
except you didn't figure out how to create
the proper container for it,
and how to merchandise that container.
What Michael spearheaded
was a packaging of talent,
the IP not the distribution
that gave his clients
and his organization the leverage,
and was able to extract
out dollars from the system
that they were entitled to that they
didn't get in the past,
no different than a players' union did
for athletes in sports.
So, what did I learn?
That it reinforced my
intuition that packaging
and merchandising is as important
as having the chops for it.
- Can you continue on this,
Michael, on packaging.
That really is something you're known for.
- So, it's important to bear in mind,
you have to, in the course of this hour
or 45 minutes we're spending together,
one has to start thinking of time frames.
Gary mentioned it articulately.
Pre-internet, post internet, a completely
different approach to distribution.
Today, if Elliot had a
good piece of content,
he wanted to put up, as Gary does also,
they can create audiences.
They can create small, niche audiences.
They can create large audiences
that cut across a large demographic.
When I worked in the
entertainment business
from the 60's, yes, the 60's,
all the way through early
2000, when the business
started to change because of the internet,
there was a very large barrier to entry.
So, if any of you out there had an idea,
there were very limited ways
to get it to the public,
very limited ways.
Actually, to be very specific,
you had CBS, NBC, ABC, later on Fox.
You had seven movie studios,
five publishing houses,
five record companies, and probably 10
different companies in Europe.
That was it.
What we tried to do is move the leverage,
as Gary mentioned, from the buy side,
who were buying your
ideas, to the sell side.
We did it by packaging ideas.
So, if Gary had an idea
for, in those days a film,
or TV show, a book, a
record, a magazine article,
or today a podcast, we would proceed
to try to add as many elements
around that as possible
before going to a buyer so
that the more elements we had,
the buyer only had two choices, yes or no.
Then we would back it up.
Today, it's a different game.
Although, I will say you can still
play the game we played in today's market.
You've done a good job of that.
- Yeah, I mean, so much
of this is about leverage.
It's kind of how I think about kindness,
in the biggest macro.
I literally think kindness
is the ultimate leverage
in perpetuity.
So, something as frothy as that,
or building community or
being an execution player.
It's all about the leverage.
If you're not commoditized,
you got a shot.
- But, with leverage comes the connotation
of non-kindness, by the way.
Because you have that leverage,
it's a question of how you use it.
I would, Gary and I were
talking before the session
with Elliot, and I will say
that in today's marketplace,
many of the things that worked in the past
probably would have to be adjusted,
and either ramped up in certain areas,
or ramped way down in others.
Leverage is a very dangerous thing
in an internet world where
everything's instantaneous,
and everything is communicated
if it's not used properly.
- How did you package Rain Man?
And, how did you break
through those walls?
- So, Rain Man started as a screen play
that was turned down by Warner Brothers.
I'll try to give you
the short story of this
cause it actually took three years
just to get it off the ground.
The studio didn't wanna do it,
which was really raw meat for CAA.
When a studio didn't wanna do something,
we wanted to show that we could do it
as being really a company
that was patterned
a lot after what MGM was in the 40's,
30's, 40's, and 50's, which
was a repository of talent.
So, anybody that had any
kind of talent at all
was somebody that MGM tried to acquire,
buy, put under contract.
We tried to do the same thing.
With Rain Man, we had a
screen play turned down
with nothing attached to it.
We immediately, after reading the script,
gave it to Dustin
Hoffman, who fell in love
with both roles, but
particularly the role,
the lead role of Raymond.
We then decided to try
to cast the other role
prior to going to a director.
We came up with the idea of Tom Cruise.
It sounds great after the fact,
but when we did it, there
was a front page article
in the Los Angeles Times
saying that we were idiots,
that there was no way that those two guys
could be brothers.
They didn't look alike.
They had nothing to do with each other.
Hoffman had gone to UCLA to meet
with the head of the doctor
who ran the autism program,
and discovered that in autistic families,
the kids don't necessarily look the same.
It's just, it's kind of
a strange part of nature.
They can or they don't have to.
In this case, the majority
of the time, they don't.
So, casting Cruise was very important
cause we wanted that demographic,
and Hoffman had his own demographic.
Long story short, we had a director,
and the director couldn't figure out
how to get the picture made quickly,
so we went to a second director.
The first director was Marty Brest,
who had done Beverly Hills Cop.
He couldn't figure it out.
We went to Barry Levinson, who ultimately
directed the picture.
He got called away to do
Good Morning, Vietnam.
We then went to Steven Spielberg,
who had trouble with the script,
and he got called away
to do something else.
We then went to Sydney Pollack,
who couldn't figure the piece out
cause it didn't have a third act.
Then, by that time, it had no third act
because an autistic person, unfortunately,
doesn't get better.
Sydney had a very linear mind.
So, he wanted to have an ending.
Anyways, in conclusion, by that time,
believe it or not, Good
Morning, Vietnam was done,
and we released it.
Levinson was available, and I called him
and said you should
really come back to this.
He went back, read the script,
and he said there is no third act.
This guy doesn't get better.
I'm gonna make a movie that I'm gonna term
two schmucks in a car.
That was the working title of the movie,
Two Schmucks in a Car.
He made a road movie,
which for those of you
that are a little older,
and I don't see many of you,
there are all these
movies made in the 40's
with Bob Hope, and Bing Crosby,
and old time movie stars
called road movies.
So, Levinson did what Picasso did.
He appropriated somebody else's idea,
which is highly acceptable, by the way,
as long as you don't infringe on their IP,
and he made a road movie.
Low and behold, the movie came out,
and it was a dismal
failure opening weekend.
- [Gary] Is that right?
- Yeah, it did $6 million for a weekend,
and the New York Times wrote an article
that Cruise, Hoffman, and Levinson
were gonna fire me, and that the head
of the studio that did the
actual, physical distribution
was gonna get fired.
What they didn't figure out
was a word of mouth movie,
and the movie did $6 million
for the next 50 weeks,
the next 50 weeks.
Then it eventually got
over $1 billion of gross,
and in that timeframe in
the 80's was important.
It won six Academy Awards.
(audience applauds)
Thank you.
I only go on about this,
and then I'll shut up,
but it's really something
to take to heart.
It's called don't ever give up
if you believe in something.
Just don't give up.
(audience applauds)
We were told don't do it.
We were told we'd get fired.
We were told that by the first director
the movie was unmakeable.
We were told by the second director,
it wasn't makeable.
The third director, same
thing, fourth director.
The movie got made, and it was a huge hit.
So, when you're into something out there,
whether it's an idea, or
a deal you're working on,
or something where you know your stomach
and your head have met each
other, just don't stop.
- [Elliot] Gary--
- Real quick, Elliot, I apologize.
Michael, when your stomach
and head have connected
on something not named Rain Man,
give us something that
has failed miserably
that your stomach and head connected,
you were sure, you saw it through,
you put your name on
it, and it shit the bed
at the theater.
(audience laughs)
- God, I'm embarrassed.
One that I worked on
with one of my partners,
probably one of the biggest disasters
we ever did was Rhinestone
with Sylvester Stallone
and Dolly Parton.
(audience laughs)
It looked really good, Gary, on paper.
- [Gary] I get it, man.
- It kinda reminds me of a football play.
For those of you who like football,
every play is designed to be perfect,
and it's a touchdown.
If that's the case, football scores
would be 270 to 220.
- [Gary] That's right.
- Instead of 20 to 15.
The reality is this had
everything going for it on paper.
She was on fire in the music area,
had five back to back hit singles.
Sly had done one giant hit
action movie after the other.
He was, at that time, the highest paid
action star in the business.
We thought we put good
creative elements around it.
I remember sitting in the theater
after the opening reel,
and getting nauseous.
So, that's one, I can give you many more.
- I think it's an important
point for all of us, right.
I love when my intro is like he invested
in Facebook and Twitter,
Tumblr, and all this stuff,
and in the back of the room, every time
before I go out stage, I'm like yeah,
but I thought Yobongo was gonna
be the biggest of them all.
Right, I think that we don't talk enough
about how no and failures
are the foundations
for yes and wins, that it's a net game,
and too many people take
an L as a scarlet letter,
which stops them from doing anything.
I think that's the important
part of the equation.
- I think another part is, too,
and I agree with that.
(audience applauds)
I think another part is that
don't take no for an answer.
I think that if you believe in something.
If you believe you can do something,
we came up with the thesis
that we could advertise
as well as an advertiser.
We thought we had the cultural roots.
We had all the connectivity.
We knew what the audience wanted
because we were a cultural enabler,
basically as an agency.
We weren't just guys, and
Gary just started an agency,
and he understands this
now better than anyone,
which is you can't just
take a phone order.
Like, is Elliot available
to be the emcee at Summit?
You can't just do that.
You have to create the
job, and go to Elliot
and say hey, I think you could do Summit.
You'd be great at it.
It'd be a great business to start.
You'd be great to lead it.
You have to be able to enable.
People said that advertising was something
that no one could do differently,
and we ended up doing
all of the advertising
for the Coca-Cola Company.
We did it for 10 years.
When we took it over, there
were 365 account executives
at McCann Erickson handling a $600 billion
a year account.
We came up with this
concept of outsourcing,
and also using our client base.
We did the same exact thing they did,
except they did six commercials a year.
We did 35 a year for 10 years.
We did it with six people, six people.
They had 365.
Now, bear in mind, this was
the beginning of outsourcing.
- Yup.
- So, when we did the polar
bears, which we created
in house at the agency,
we had 300 animators,
but not working for us.
They were on somebody else's payroll.
Whereas, at the other company,
they were hiring all these
people, trying to manage them.
It made no sense.
So again, another example
about being pragmatic,
being confident, being
bold, and attempting
to get in front of all the
criticism and negativity.
- In order to win that specific account,
is it true that you did
it for no commission?
How did that story go down?
- I happened to be at a conference,
a smaller version of this
called the Allen and Company Conference.
The CEO of Coke and the
COO of Coke were there.
We were sitting, having a coffee
in a very casual
environment in Sun Valley,
and they were complaining that Pepsi-Cola
was starting to beat them on case sales.
There's a book out, many years
old, called The Cola Wars.
They were about as
competitive and cutthroat.
You couldn't get any more cutthroat.
Matter of fact, one of the subsequent CEOs
of Coca-Cola was once asked
at a group meeting like this,
with 1,200 people in the audience,
what would he do if he was
with the CEO of Pepsi-Cola,
and the CEO fell out of the boat.
He said I'd shove a garden
hose down his throat.
(audience laughs)
Needless to say, he got fired.
But, that's how competitive they were.
Our goal, at the time, was
not to be in that business,
but my goal was to always
listen for new ideas
and new things that we could do.
Every day when I came in,
and Gary knows this feeling,
you walk in and you have
1,000 people working for you,
when he walks into his media company,
he's gotta start generating ideas himself.
He's gotta be generating ideas
in people that work for him.
He's gotta be figuring out
how to pay the overhead
and how to grow the business,
how to make it an
interesting place to work.
It's a never, being a CEO/Founder,
there's never enough hours in the day,
and it never ends, never ends.
We basically said to them that,
they asked me if I'd take a look at it.
We said yes, and we did.
Six months later, we had the account.
- I wanna talk about hard
work, and get into it
cause we're sitting here, two Goliaths,
but really, your stories, and
how you relate your story,
is about being the Davids.
There's a paragraph in
your book, just came out,
Who Is Michael Ovitz?,
that I really related to
because it gets into the specifics.
I'd love for you each to kind of continue
this paragraph after I read it.
As agents, we didn't agree on anything.
We were sellers.
We sold our clients
our time and expertise,
and then we sold the buyers our clients.
Our tenuous capital was
the hours in the day,
less the few we slept,
and we spent that capital
at frenzied pace.
I'd drop everything to get
you the right cardiac surgeon,
the right car, a place for your kid
at the John Thomas Dye or
Harvard-Westlake Schools,
whatever you needed.
I was everyone's chief psychiatrist,
legal advisor, financial
fixer, cultural translator,
and shoulder to cry on.
- Would you take that first.
- Period.
- Cause you're doing it now.
- [Elliot] Period.
- You're doing it, I did it.
- Yeah, I mean look, I think that,
I think everybody here
could be empathetic.
How many people here, by show of hands,
are running their company,
or are the founder
of their company, the
last line of defense.
Just raise it.
An enormous amount.
Look, I think, thank god,
we're having very detailed,
nuanced conversations in culture
about work-life balance,
about proper rest,
about meditation, mental health.
That makes me happy.
I think a lot of times I love hard work
as a competitive advantage, but I get
thrown under the bus
of somebody who doesn't
believe in what I do believe in,
which is self-awareness.
Like, if this is what you love,
and you love your process,
I have no interest in judging
anybody's work-life balance,
how they parent, or how
they live their lives
cause I don't know the context.
Who here would, I would
never want somebody
to work so hard, or be stressed so much
that they commit suicide,
or they don't feel well.
That'd be ludicrous, that's ludicrous.
At the same token, I have no interest
in judging somebody who's so passionate
about their work, or the things that they
want to see in the world,
that during this period
in their life, they're willing
to make that commitment
to that product.
Everybody who just
raised their hands knows,
how many people of the people
that raised their hands
also have a child?
Raise your hand.
Your business is the other child.
You love it that much.
It's just the truth.
So, what do I think?
I think when you're the
last line of defense
within an organization, you're always on.
It's just a cost of entry.
I also think for a lot
of people in this room
it's the only way they could breathe.
On the flip side, the
thing I am concerned about
is that I do think entrepreneurship,
or being CEO, has been
glamorized over the last decade,
and I do think that people are
not deploying self-awareness,
and I do believe that a
high number of the hands
that went up are actually more suited
to be a number two or three,
but that the coolness,
and the excitement, and
just the sheer amount
of money in the system to
fund to be a number one
is attractive to people.
There's a part of me that loves it
because I want everybody
to take a swing at it,
but to me, it's about self-awareness.
He loved it.
Do you know how much I love when somebody
comes into my office and
says Karen's ruining me?
Like, I'm the head of HR, like, I love it.
But, three of my calls today were people
who were not satisfied with their raise.
I'm worried about the leak in the roof
in our Chattanooga, Tennessee office.
I love it.
It's what I like to do.
My brother hated managing people
which is why he left VaynerMedia,
and now is trying to be Jerry Maguire.
So, I think self-awareness matters,
but to me, when I hear that,
I'm like uh huh, uh huh.
I wake up, we have a London office.
We're opening up Singapore.
When I wake up, I look at my phone
to make sure if there's
any fire I need to put out.
I literally, you know, you
don't have to do it anymore
with global entry, but for the last year
that I was filling out the passport thing
where it said occupation, I
literally wrote firefighter.
(audience laughs)
Because that's what we do.
We're always on, ready to go,
and when you're reverse
engineering a client,
whether it's an organization or a human,
you are there for them, and so if you need
to be their financial advisor,
or cultural interpreter,
or you gotta pick up their dog,
these are things that
you're signing up for
when you're in the
client services business.
It fucking sucks, but
it's the cost of entry.
- I think it is the most
complicated discussion
that could possibly be had.
I think that to be a CEO/Founder
is probably one of the most
difficult jobs on the planet.
I work with a lot of
founders up in the Bay Area.
It's what I do now.
I think their job is impossible.
Every time you think you
have something under control,
you have a leak in the
roof in Chattanooga.
- That's right.
- The reality is that one
of the pieces of advice,
as simple and stupid as it
sounds, that I've given,
is that when you think
things are going well,
you're gonna walk around the corner
and someone's gonna wack you in the shins
with a two by four because they never
ever go well.
I had an incident with a startup up north
that's done exceedingly well, taken off
like a rocket ship on one of the advisors.
I went in at the recommendation
of one of the investors
to invest and advise.
I did.
I met with the two young founders,
both brilliant, young engineers, mid 20's,
and I said look, I'm gonna
give you a little bit
of advice that I was asked to give you.
You won't listen to it.
You won't agree with it.
When I walk outta here, you're gonna say
that old guy is really an idiot.
I'm not gonna blame you for thinking that,
but within six months,
you're gonna call me
cause you've got a problem.
When I left, I looked back, and they
were snickering a little, and
probably saying the things
that I thought they would, and
that they probably should've.
Well, I was wrong.
It wasn't six months, it
was four months later.
I was in Palo Alto.
My phone rings.
I was shocked it was one of the founders,
shocked because he never
used the phone in his life.
His idea of a communication
was a three word text.
The words how are you feeling
never came out of his mouth.
The first thing that I
heard was do you remember
when you told us something would happen
that we didn't expect.
I said yes.
He said, "Well, it happened."
I said tell me.
They told me that their
business had gotten shut down
because they'd been hacked by some
rogue Nigerian hackers,
which because I do work
for a company called Palantir,
I actually advised them
was going to happen.
They were shut down, and they were
in the e-commerce business.
Now, for those of you that
are on the consumer side,
picture yourself shutdown on a weekend,
which is your highest traffic day.
In any case, they had no relationships.
They never reached out to anybody.
They never cultivated any
relationships with anybody.
I was fortunate enough
to had just had dinner
with the man who ran
PayPal, who just happened
to purchase the company
that shut them down.
I called that person, congratulated him
on his sale, said by the way,
can you do me a favor.
Of course, he did.
They were back up.
That lesson to them did not go unheeded.
That lesson of trying
to build relationships,
build a network, deal with people,
and try to make sure that you put in
a certain amount of
time in that direction.
Going back to the question at hand,
it's very hard when you're a workaholic
like Gary or myself, and
you enjoy the action.
You just enjoy the day to day fight.
You enjoy every part of it.
One has to remember as a founder,
you can't expect everyone in your staff
to have the same persona that you do.
- I actually think you can't.
I'm also an investor and
advisor in a lot of businesses,
and obviously get a ton of DMs and emails
from entrepreneurs.
The audacity for you to want somebody
who's not compensated in
the same way that you are,
to work the same way that you do
is one of the great shocking things
that I watch about.
Gary, I want them to work as hard as I do.
I'm like give them 50% of the business.
(audience laughs)
It's ludicrous.
I have never, I have
actually, I've been fascinated
by that.
I've never had the expectation of any,
I feel like the almost thousand people
that I work for, which is the other thing
that you learn very quickly
if you're a good leader
or entrepreneur, or a
CEO, is you work for them.
They don't work for you, which is why
so many through your careers struggled
with the transition from being a doer
to being a manager, cause you thought
that was the graduation, and
it's actually the reverse.
That's why people struggle with that.
It's crazy to me that
people have that audacity.
- I think you raised a really good point
about the fact that you
work for all your employees.
I do think that there
is a way, and you do it.
I watched you do it when
I'm up at your office.
I did the same thing, which is
you can only lead by example.
It's the only thing you can do.
- Yeah, but, me going at it hard, for me,
I think I wanna know the context.
Everybody's driven by different things.
Some people are driven by titles.
Some people are driven by finances.
Some people are driven
by work-life balance.
For me, it's always being on.
Today, Sarah wants money.
Next week, she falls in love,
and she wants to spend
more time with that person.
So, she needs a little time off.
In four years, somebody
that used to work for her
now has a bigger title than her.
You're just always on.
I feel like not only do I
have to reverse engineer
what they care about, you know, period,
I have to be that way in
perpetuity while they're with me
because they're gonna have to evolve.
They will evolve, and I have to create
the foundation for them
to be able to navigate.
Otherwise, I don't bring value,
and they have to find an alternative.
- That goes to the point that
it is incredibly complex.
- Massive.
- Look at the roadmap you just drew.
Those that lead have to
make certain sacrifices
to those who don't.
- You know what, that brings
up an interesting point.
The other thing that I
think is super interesting
is that it's in perpetuity.
I always laughed that people boo or cheer
in the second quarter.
Let me promise you one thing.
How many people, again,
running their own company?
It's hard, right?
Guess what, this is the
easiest time to do it.
The amount of fucking
money that's in the system,
and the amount of you that
have bullshit businesses
that actually aren't
businesses, but are funded,
being serious, this is
something we have to talk about.
If you think it's hard
now, one of the things
that I'm most proud of
is that from the day
I started running my dad's business,
20 plus years ago to this moment,
I've been running the
company, and I've never
had a credit line that
I took for Wine Library.
I never raised capital.
I've paid my bills weekly in perpetuity.
I have never lost $6 million this year,
and did all my behavior
to get enough CAC and LTV
to get the next fundraising round.
You do understand that everybody's
about to get smoked the fuck out, right?
(audience laughs)
Everybody's so over-leveraged.
They don't have businesses.
They have VC arbitraged machines
for the next fundraising.
I'll see you all working
at Bank of America
in a couple years.
(audience applauds)
It's 100% true.
Let me say this.
I'm not sitting up here like I'm cool
and I'm razzing you.
I'm hoping that that hits you in a way
that says fuck, maybe I should actually
build a business, not
something that appeases
the VCs who have no vested
interest in my business
to get the next fundraising round.
That's how you'll navigate the shit.
You'll be practical.
(audience applauds)
I like how many people clapped
verses how many people did not.
(audience laughs)
- I might hope that maybe somebody
might make a pivot just.
- Michael, look, I think one of the things
I'm most fascinated by right now
is there's so much money in the system.
- Right.
- And if you follow where
the money comes from,
that's an interesting thing
to debate in the first place.
But, let's leave that for another day.
I am fascinated by people thinking
that not making more profit than expenses
is not something you need
to think about a lot more.
Like, I'm just watching
people spend all their time
on like influencer
marketing, and CAC, and MNA,
and like, when the money dries out,
there's a lot of young
people in this system.
You didn't live through
2007 as an operator.
You were in college having fun.
You didn't live through 2001.
We have never been this over leveraged.
When the dominoes fall, and there's no
next fundraising round, or
when you're an influencer,
and nobody's got $8,000 for you
to take a picture with
a fucking toothpaste
in your hand, it's not gonna be fun
to go from traveling the world
as an influencer to no
money in the system,
and you have to go get a job.
I want people to be prepared,
and everyone's living
in fucking La-La Land.
We've been living in
La-La Land for a decade,
which makes me nervous as fuck.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- [Elliot] I wanna ask a
question about deal making.
Looking back on it--
(audience laughs)
- The segue is always so hard.
- To continue, it's just
going right on this.
I just wanna ask.
- After what he said, I'm gonna retire.
(audience laughs)
Cause there's no hope.
There's no hope.
- Actually, that was super hopeful.
- I guess it was.
- No, it really was.
The no hope is to live in the delusion
that if you run a business, losing money
is a viable option.
- Well, but I agree with that.
- Well, guess what,
Michael, this is fucking
an ecosystem right now that
is built on losing money.
- And I happen to believe that
that is something that's gonna change.
I think that the people that
are handing out the money
while they still have it--
- Correct.
- Are starting to think through,
and probably listening to your podcast.
- Cause everybody,
because what Michael knows
way better than I do,
but I've got at least
a gray hair or two to know,
this is what always happens.
We're not guessing up here.
This is cycles.
When you haven't been through one,
you don't know the context.
- When we started CAA, we
started with a very small
amount of debt.
We borrowed $100,000.
We paid it off four
months after we started.
We had zero debt for the entire time
I was at the company.
The reason was exactly, and again,
this is 40 years ago, and the reason
was exactly what Gary is saying.
40 years ago, it was the same problem.
There was too much cash in the system.
There were a lot of
businesses starting out
that shouldn't have started out.
There were a lot of
businesses starting out
that should've started out, but they were
over funded and worried.
They weren't worried
about making a profit.
I will say, and I can
speak for Gary on this
because I admire how he runs his business,
when I ran CAA, there was only one thing
that was important, and that
was secondary, of course,
to our people, which was
the most important thing,
most important, and
we've commented on that.
But, it was to turn a profit, and not
to be in anybody's back pocket,
and not have anybody being in a position
to tell us what to do.
We were gonna rise or
fall on our own deeds,
our own brains, our own will power,
and what we could do.
So, it's a, to me, past is prologue.
When Gary mentioned cycles,
it's the same way to say it.
History always repeats itself.
We're seeing that now in the stock market.
We're going to see it.
We're seeing it in world affairs,
and we're seeing it up
north in the startup area.
We're seeing it with black
swan companies as well.
I mean, let's not forget that as good
as Apple's report was yesterday,
the stock was still,
when I last looked down,
$15 today before I turned my phone off.
So, we're in a very
cyclic world right now.
- I wanna ask one more question
to expand right on this.
I think it's a fun way to end.
You guys have been fantastic.
I wanna ask you, Gary, you say
it's your number one thesis,
so much of what we can learn about how
the world works is based on this.
Hip hop rules the world.
- So, I think that if you look,
Michael said something super important,
which was that history repeats itself.
I think if you really study the impact
that rock and roll had on our society,
all the way through to
legislation, governments,
the way we feel about many issues,
I would argue that for many of us
who are between the ages of 35 to 55,
who, if you just look at history,
had a very big impact on where the world
goes and how, that many of us grew up
in a hip hop environment,
and with that seed,
where I look at, it's crazy for me
to see Cypress Hill is The Who.
Run DMC and Beastie
Boys are Rolling Stones.
It's amazing to see history repeat itself.
So, look, I study where the pebble is
that starts waves.
If you look at what, to me the fact
that I can map back some
trends that are impacting
14 and 15 year old girls in Kansas
to what Gunna was doing
in Atlanta 36 months ago
as he was an emerging hip hop artist,
is fascinating to me how much,
and I would even go even more specific,
that right this minute Atlanta's impact
on our culture overall is fascinating
because who does that
hip hop person influence,
it's an athlete which then
influences an influencer,
which influences a teenage girl.
You would be fascinated
if you're as nerdy as I am
of how the reboot of women wearing jeans
with rips in them that started
23 and a half months ago,
why that happened, the fucking why's
on what is happening in
our world are fascinating,
and I think hip hop has
a much bigger impact
on it than people realize.
(audience applauds)
- I've maintained privately and publicly
that the hip hop generation, basically,
which a number of people in my generation
and the generation behind me
though was gonna fade out,
is not only here to stay, but I feel
it dictates the cultural
agenda of the country.
I have to say I think it's a good thing.
I think it's opening up people's minds.
I can't say I agree with
all the lyrics that I hear,
but I do think that it's kind of the,
which is gonna sound ridiculously
stupid to all of you,
but in the 60's, when
the rock and roll groups
from England came over,
the Beatles, The Who,
the Stones, and they wore this,
what today doesn't look like long hair.
There was an actual debate
about whether or not
the Beatles or Elvis
Presley would be allowed
on a Sunday night television show
called The Ed Sullivan Show, which was
on Sunday nights at 8:00,
in the family hour on CBS,
was a variety television show.
This went on for months,
and debated in the press,
A, whether Presley should be allowed
because of the way he gyrated his hips.
This is true by the way.
This was actually discussed all the way up
to government levels.
And, whether the Beatles
should be allowed on
because their hair was so long.
I think if we fade out to today,
it's exactly the same thing.
- 1000%.
- With a different costume,
and I think it's a good thing.
- That was a fast hour.
That was an unbelievable hour.
Let's give a huge round of applause
to Gary Vee and Michael Ovitz.
(audience applauds)